[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
cuando nancy pelosi la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de los eeuu
visitó taiwán el día 2 de agosto del
2022 los chinos o mejor dicho en el
gobierno chino se volvieron locos el
resultado es que el gobierno de
schilling ping ha puesto la tensión en
la zona al rojo vivo de esta forma
además de condenar la visita china puso
en marcha enormes ejercicios militares
rodeó la isla y desplegó aviones de
guerra y un montón de barcos e incluso
el ejército chino disparó misiles
balísticos frente a las costas de taiwán
y por primera vez cuatro de ellos
sobrevolaron la propia isla claro que
ese tipo de provocaciones no son algo
estrictamente nuevo
[Música]
por ejemplo las incursiones de la fuerza
aérea china en la zona de identificación
de defensa aérea de taiwán son ya algo
cotidiano
bombarderos cazas aviones de vigilancia
helicópteros por allí pasa de todo
constantemente lo que obliga a las
fuerzas taiwanesa a estar
permanentemente en alerta la cuestión de
taiwán ha dejado de ser una especie de
asunto estrecho de boutique y se ha
convertido en un teatro central sino en
el drama central en la competencia
estratégica entre eeuu y china evans
medeiros experto en asuntos asiáticos y
miembros del consejo de seguridad
nacional de la administración obama a
medida que los eeuu y las fuerzas
externas incluidas las fuerzas de
independencia de taiwán hagan
provocaciones constantes los ejercicios
serán más intensos y más frecuentes más
amplios en tiempo y alcance con song
ping analista militar y ex oficial del
ejército chino el caso es que durante
los últimos años la cuestión de taiwán
está cobrando cada vez más protagonismo
en la agenda internacional y
especialmente en la agenda del gobierno
chino
aquí en visual político hemos publicado
unos cuantos vídeos ya sobre este tema
os hemos hablado por ejemplo sobre cómo
podría defenderse taiwán sobre que
podría aprender de ucrania sobre las
razones que están detrás de la
reivindicación china y de otras muchas
cuestiones por el estilo sin embargo nos
falta responder a unas cuantas preguntas
absolutamente claves a que viene tanto
interés repentino por taiwán porque tras
la visita de pelosi el gobierno de jean
ping perdió de tal forma los papeles
cuál será el siguiente paso de pekín a
qué riesgo se enfrenta realmente taiwán
en un futuro próximo pues bien vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas y lo
primero que os parece es saber cuáles
son los cinco motivos que explican por
qué china parece cada vez más
obsesionada con taiwán ya os adelanto
que en esta receta tenemos ingredientes
de todo tipo militares políticos
económicos diplomáticos de todo atentos
[Música]
una cuestión made in china
el gobierno de sillín ping está elevando
el tono sobre taiwán no es algo para
nada casual como ya os hemos dicho son
al menos cinco los motivos que explican
esta virulenta reacción y sabéis que los
dos primeros tienen mucho que ver con la
propia política de siguen fin
en primer lugar a finales del 2022 el
líder chino desafiar al hasta ahora
tradicional limitación de mandatos del
partido comunista chino de esta forma se
asegurará seguir al frente del país
durante al menos un tercer mandato esto
es algo que no ocurría desde la época de
mao pero amigos xi jinping no quiere
abandonar el poder
[Música]
y claro no hay nada mejor para legitimar
su posición que promover un discurso
tremendamente nacionalista y presentarse
como el líder que devolverá a china toda
su grandeza en ese caso el líder que por
fin puso a hong kong bajo el control
total de pekín y que próximamente lo
hará con taiwán claro que un momento
porque ese no es el único objetivo del
creciente nacionalismo del gobierno
chino la otra razón tiene mucho que ver
con desviar la atención de algo que ya
se hemos contado aquí en visual político
[Música]
la economía china no está atravesando su
mejor momento salvando el coronavirus su
crecimiento es el más bajo en 30 años el
desempleo joven no deja de crecer y el
país está al borde de sufrir una enorme
crisis económica y quizás también
financiera
en otras palabras que consiguen para la
prosperidad china se está derrumbando y
con ello también lo está haciendo el
histórico pacto tácito entre el partido
comunista y la sociedad china ya sabéis
eso de vosotros no cuestiones al
gobierno ni al partido comunista y a
cambio os mandamases de pekín os
garantizamos prosperidad y una rápida
mejora en los niveles de vida bueno la
pregunta es que hace todo buen político
cuando fracasa en su objetivo
fundamental en una idea exacta sacarse
otra de la chistera
cuando la economía va de mal en peor no
resulta extraño que los políticos se
inventen de repente otras
reivindicaciones en este caso de una
agenda mucho más nacionalista lo que
incluye el tema de taiwán de repente
para el gobierno chino el crecimiento y
la prosperidad parece haber dejado de
ser una prioridad ahora lo que realmente
importa es recuperar la grandeza de la
gran nación china lo que se conoce como
el gran rejuvenecimiento nacional a
pesar de que bueno china cada vez tiene
una población más envejecida de hecho la
burbuja inmobiliaria comenzó a explotar
cuando evergrande una de las grandes
promotoras inmobiliarias chinas se vino
abajo el colapso de esta compañía
comenzó a ser bien conocido al menos
públicamente aproximadamente a partir
del mes de septiembre del 2021 pues
fijaos en lo que sigue y me decía al
poco tiempo 11 de octubre del 2021 xi
jinping dice que la reunificación es
imprescindible para el rejuvenecimiento
de china ya lo veis es una cuestión de
puro interés político claro que junto a
estos también podemos encontrar motivos
de corte militar económico y diplomático
por ejemplo el tercer motivo por el que
te one despierta de repente interés en
pekín tiene mucho que ver con la
modernización de las fuerzas armadas de
este país
[Música]
veréis me explicó durante los últimos
años el ejército chino se ha modernizado
y ha crecido en capacidades así que
ahora su objetivo pasa por extender su
influencia por toda la región pues bien
en esta línea taiwán es algo así como
una llave para acceder tanto al mar de
la china meridional como al propio
océano pacifico dos objetivos necesarios
para la operatividad de la armada china
de hecho como veis la isla de formosa es
el eslabón principal de una cadena de
islas que ha llegado el caso podría
bloquear a la armada china y eso no es
todo si te bueno estuviera bajo dominio
chino además de tener más facilidad para
extender su influencia en la región
conseguiría un control enorme sobre una
de las rutas comerciales más importantes
del planeta
el estrecho de taiwán es una de las
rutas marítimas más concurridas de todo
el planeta casi la mitad de los buques
contenedores incluyendo el 88% de los de
clase más grande pasan por allí hablamos
de la ruta principal para los barcos que
transportan mercancías desde china a
japón y corea del sur hacia el oeste y
también claro está de la ruta principal
a través de la cual estos mismos países
se abastecen de energía
[Música]
en otras palabras adversarios de china
como corea del sur o japón dependerían
de pekín para llevar a término buena
parte de sus exportaciones o
aprovisionarse de casi petróleo y aún
más llegado el caso cayhuan podría ser
utilizado por eeuu como una especie de
portaaviones y centro de
aprovisionamiento y taiwán volviera a
estar bajo el control de pekín es el
riesgo desaparecería por completo así
que he visto de esta forma la presión
china parece una consecuencia lógica del
creciente peso militar del gigante
asiático pero amigos amigas aún no hemos
terminado como os decíamos también
podemos encontrar otros dos claros
motivos uno económico y otro diplomático
prestar mucha atención
[Música]
un bloqueo de chips y una medida de
presión
[Música]
la república popular china lleva años
preparando a sus fuerzas armadas para
invadir taiwán por ejemplo ha construido
la mayor armada del mundo por número de
barcos algo que como veréis puede ser
mucho más importante de lo que podríamos
pensar a simple vista y no sólo eso el
llamado ejército popular de liberación
de la china continental también está
incrementando y mucho su presencia en
torno a taiwán sin embargo el primer
paso en un hipotético conflicto podría
ser muy distinto en varios vídeos
anteriores aquí en visual político ya os
hemos contado como taiwán podría
prepararse para que cualquier invasión
tuviera un coste excesivamente alto para
pekín y la experiencia rusa en ucrania
es por así decirlo toda una llamada de
atención por eso el régimen comunista
podría intentar una estrategia diferente
bloquear la isla de formosa a sus 23
millones de habitantes por mar y aire es
decir aislar a taiwán para hacerse con
el control de la situación y obtener
concesiones de taipei esa estrategia por
cierto no resulta para nada casual
fijaos en este mapa la mayor parte de la
población de la industria y de los
puertos de taiwán se concentran
precisamente en el flanco occidental de
la isla es decir justo frente a las
costas de la china continental de esta
forma utilizando decenas y decenas
quizás cientos de barcos de guerra y
submarinos baking podría impedir que los
buques mercantes entraran o salieran de
la isla sellando también con ello una de
las rutas comerciales más concurridas
del mundo y una vía imprescindible para
la economía de conesa de la misma forma
la enorme superioridad númerica de las
fuerzas aéreas chinas junto a sus nuevos
portaaviones abrirán también permitirles
cerrar a cal y canto' su espacio aéreo y
algo muy similar podrían hacer también
en gran medida con el ciberespacio como
pues cortando o desactivando los cables
submarinos que transportan en torno al
90% de los datos que conectan esta isla
con el resto del mundo
[Música]
el caso es que un bloqueo de estas
características podría forzar
rápidamente una negociación o disuadir a
taipei de tomar decisiones que no gusten
en pekín asimismo al no ser
estrictamente una acción de guerra o al
menos un ataque directo a la isla esto
podría hacer que eeuu y otros aliados
apostarán por la vía diplomática como
respuesta además taiwán tiene una gran
dependencia tanto de las importaciones
de combustibles y alimentos como de las
exportaciones que forman el núcleo
central de su economía así que es
posible que la isla no pudiera soportar
un bloqueo de estas características por
mucho tiempo no al menos sin sufrir
grandes pérdidas
y eso no es todo queridos amigos echa el
freno porque justo aquí tenemos que
tenerlo en su momento recordáis que gran
éxito ha tenido la industria taiwanesa
en los últimos años alguna idea sí
verdad exacto taiwán se ha convertido en
la meca de los chips
[Música]
los chips son pequeños circuitos
integrados que se han convertido en el
componente indispensable de la evolución
tecnológica desde el arnold o tecnología
hasta la robótica desde los f 35 hasta
los drones pasando por los smartphones
que todos llevamos en nuestro bolsillo
todos los aparatos modernos necesitan de
estos pequeños componentes en cierta
forma la carrera tecnológica incluyendo
el campo militar se ha convertido ya en
una carrera por hacerse con los mejores
chips
[Música]
sabéis que taiwán se ha convertido en el
epicentro mundial de la fabricación de
chips avanzados lo que quiere decir que
hoy por hoy taiwán es un lugar clave
para la industria tecnológica y la
industria militar de eeuu sin embargo un
bloqueo chino podría interrumpir las
cadenas de suministros lo que como veis
afectaría directamente a la seguridad
nacional de la potencia norteamericana
de hecho durante su visita nancy pelosi
se reunió con los mandamases de tsm el
mayor fabricante de chips del mundo al
tiempo que el senador por massachusetts
ed markey se reunió con responsables de
la empresa para discutir inversiones y
formas de mejorar las cadenas de
suministros de chips ese era uno de los
puntos clave de la visita y no sólo eso
el propio gobierno de taiwán por cierto
galardonada con el premio visual
político considera que hoy por hoy esta
dependencia internacional de los chips
es la mejor garantía para la
supervivencia de taiwán el problema es
que la industria china también necesita
chips de hecho el gigante asiático
importa marc chips que petróleo tan solo
en 2021 importo chips por valor de 430
mil millones de dólares por cierto el 36
por ciento de ellos procedieron de
taiwán de esta forma la carrera por
taiwán se ha convertido también en una
carrera por los chips más avanzados
quien domina el mercado mundial de chips
tendrá la supremacía tecnológica y
también militar para las dos grandes
superpotencias es un asunto de
supervivencia en su condición de tales
josep piqué director de la revista
política exterior así que ya lo veis en
este peligroso juego un posible bloqueo
chino de la isla de formosa es un riesgo
real no solo como medida de presión
contra taiwán sino llegado el caso
también contra washington
[Música]
así que aquí tenemos otros dos buenos
motivos que explican tanto interés
repentino por taiwán por un lado la
preocupación de taiwán le permitiría a
china hacerse con una de las industrias
y tecnologías más importantes del mundo
por otro la ocupación o incluso la
amenaza de bloquear la isla le puede dar
un enorme tanto diplomático sería
llegado el caso un elemento de presión
brutal contra eeuu europa y el resto del
mundo china podría cortar o al menos
amenazar con cortar la cadena de
suministros de chips y eso eso son
palabras mayores pero amigos aún no
hemos terminado la pregunta ahora es a
qué escenario nos enfrentamos realmente
veremos un intento de invasión en el
corto plazo cómo puede protegerse taiwán
pues atentos
[Música]
una armadura contra la persistencia de
pekín
con todo lo que acabamos de ver podemos
esperar que las amenazas chinas no se
detengan y esto pone sobre la mesa
varias cuestiones la primera es que
puede hacer taiwán para disuadir a china
de pasar de la retórica a la acción es
algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado lo
primero que hay que hacer taiwán es
hacer que cualquier posible invasión se
convierta en un enorme quebradero de
cabeza es lo que se conoce como la
estrategia del puercoespín
si algo nos muestra la guerra de ucrania
es precisamente que la guerra asimétrica
utilizando sistemas móviles como los
misiles antitanques avelino o los
misiles antiaéreos stinger pueden ser si
estos se despliegan en grandes
cantidades tremendamente eficaces contra
fuerzas mucho mejor equipadas por eso
cada vez son más los expertos en el
campo militar que dicen que esto es
precisamente lo que tiene que hacer
taiwán prepararse a fondo para una
guerra asimétrica a gran escala misiles
drones helicópteros plataformas de
disparos sistemas antiaéreos artillería
de precisión minas torpedos pero que
llegado el caso resultarían mucho más
efectivos que carísimos submarinos o
tanques así mismo también tendrían que
prepararse para entrenar a una parte
creciente de su población y esto es algo
que podría lograrse promoviendo clubes
de tiros o formando una especie de
guardia territorial
claro que eso no elimina ni el riesgo de
bloqueo y tampoco el daño económico que
la creciente hostilidad con china le
puede causar
[Música]
en esta línea reforzar la asociación con
sus aliados internacionales tanto desde
el punto económico como militar se
convierte en un paso imprescindible
precisamente por eso ewan ha pedido la
adhesión al cpp y está negociando un
acuerdo de libre comercio con eeuu
taiwán tiene que convertirse desde
cualquier punto de vista en el mejor
aliado de eeuu europa japón y el resto
de países aliados sea como sea quizás la
mejor noticia es que por ahora la guerra
de ucrania puede haber frenado o al
menos por un tiempo la enorme ambición
de xi jinping ucrania ha demostrado que
las cosas pueden terminar siendo muy
diferentes a como fueron con crimea y
hong kong cuando la comunidad
internacional apenas reaccionó y eso eso
es una extraordinaria noticia para
taiwán con todo no parece probable que
el objetivo de china sea intentar una
invasión en un futuro próximo
probablemente el objetivo de pekín sea
algo más elaborado y se parezca mucho
más a lo que se hizo con hong kong esto
es incrementar su influencia económica
sobre la isla mientras se incrementa y
prepara su fuerza militar para llegado
el caso amenazar con un bloqueo y buscar
concesiones para un proceso de
integración progresivo
eso sería algo así como la trampa
perfecta y por eso siguen ping ya su
gobierno les irrita tanto que taiwán
esté volviendo a estrechar lazos con
occidente
de hecho la creciente retórica china
podría buscar también elevar el riesgo
país de taiwán para castigar su economía
y sus lazos con occidente así que
teniendo todo esto en cuenta el
escenario más probable es que la
retórica china vaya a más y no a menos
con el paso del tiempo pero llegas hasta
aquí turno para ti qué crees que hará
finalmente china con taiwán incrementará
sus amenazas o en cambio buscará rebajar
la tensión para aproximarse a la isla
será el congreso del partido comunista
el punto de inflexión para que las cosas
cambien y seguramente la pregunta más
importante de todas que debe hacer la
comunidad internacional déjanos por aquí
abajo tus impresiones y abramos debate
como siempre si este vídeo ya resulta
interesante no olvides darle al botón de
like y suscribir te avisa al político si
es que aún no lo has hecho muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]